what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future so for this
installment of our vs. series we're
actually gonna be taking a step away
from the mobile vs. DC line of comics
and actually want to focus on Franklin
Richards versus the white lantern kyle
rayner god this is gonna be a fun one
the reason why is because these
characters have actually both been
featured in my how to kill superhero
series has all that'd be kind of cool to
like pit them against one another and
see which one would come out on top so
like always we're going to go through
each of these characters relatively
briefly and then decide what winner
we're gonna have just because the fact
that we've run over this stuff before so
first and foremost Franklin's mutant
powers allow him to warp reality and by
this I mean that he can do literally
anything any thought that he has
Franklin can make it real and so if
something exists that he doesn't want to
exist any more he could make that happen
if something doesn't exist that he wants
to bring into reality he can bring that
into existence as well and so he can
really manipulate the molecules that
make up matter thereby altering the
chemical makeup of literally any object
or person to make them exactly how he
wants them to be in other words anything
Franklin wants to do he can do now in
addition to warping reality Franklin is
a powerful telepath and telekinetic
Franklin's telepathic abilities are so
strong that they're able to grant him
precognition or the ability to see into
the future although this ability is
limited to only a few days into the
future now as if that weren't enough
Franklin can produce powerful blasts of
energy that can project himself into the
astral plane
what makes this battle more interesting
however is that in addition to being
exceptionally powerful Franklin seems to
be immortal as he wants remarks to
Galactus that the two of them will be
the only ones left when the universe is
destroyed and reformed as the question
is just how powerful is Franklin well
the comics have yet to establish any
upper limit to his abilities but there
are several feats that he has performed
they give us some idea of his power
level
Franklin's reality warping power is so
advanced that he was able to create a
pocket universe he's also shown an
ability to neutralize the powers of
other superhumans by constructing a box
that negated the destructive quality of
blackballs voice so that he can speak
normally and has turned an energy
blasphemous
joël into a harmless stream of flowers
Franklin has traveled to the realm of
Mephisto one of the most powerful demons
of Marvel Comics and defeated him and
has even turned Galactus into his Herald
during Jonathan Hickman's run on
Fantastic Four Franklin has also used
his reality warping ability as a defense
mechanism several times
he's withstood a Celestials physical
attack as well as one of their energy
blasts and in fact to get an idea of how
powerful Franklin is it's been stated
that the Celestials consider Franklin to
possess power equal to them know as
powerful as he is Franklin
is not without his weaknesses first of
all this fight has immense power his
physical body does not seem to be
enhanced in any way all the feats of
defense and durability that we've talked
about before are seemingly the
byproducts of his reality warping
instead of any actual physical
durability and so if that's the case as
it seems to be then without
reality-warping power Franklin is just
as vulnerable as any other human being
another notable weakness really only
affects Franklin at certain points
depending on how he's being written at
the time but it's worth mentioning
nonetheless what I mean by this is that
at various times throughout his history
Franklin Richards has been depicted at
being various ages more often he's
depicted as a child but sometimes we see
an adult version of Franklin the child
version of Franklin now has a particular
weakness and that he's only ever
depicted as being too immature and
inexperienced to be in full control of
his powers
not only does that mean that Franklin
does not have access to the full extent
of his abilities we could also possibly
cause unintentional harm to himself or
others and so clearing out Franklin
Richards what I want to do is I want to
transition over to Kyle Rayner now the
first thing we need to understand is
that each of the various lantern colors
correspond to an emotion within the
emotional spectrum the green lanterns
correspond to willpower blue to hope red
to rage yellow to fear orange degreed
indigo to compassion and violet which is
personified by the star sapphire core to
love as a white Lantern
Kyle Rayner is the embodiment of all
these colors and their corresponding
emotions that such Kyle possesses all
the powers of each of the lantern cores
this means that he can create constructs
powered by will like the Green Lantern's
or fear like the yellow lanterns also
known as a Sinestro Corps he can emit
poisonous blood like the Red Lanterns
heal injuries like the blue lanterns
steal the identities of those he's
defeated like Larfleeze the orange
lantern force people to feel loved like
the star sapphires and teleport like the
indigo lanterns in addition to these
abilities Kyle possesses several skills
that are unique
to the White Lantern Corps such as
resurrecting the dead creating light
constructs of light energy phasing
through solid objects generating force
fields creating energy blasts going
invisible healing himself flying at
super speeds and manipulating reality
now as powerful as Kyle is he can become
even more powerful as he embraces the
power of life which fuels the white
lantern ring at one time
Kyle's White Lantern ring contained the
life equation a mathematical equation
proving the value of life and Kyle
acquired the equation after passing
through the source wall which is an
interdimensional barrier in the DC
universe once thought to be impenetrable
as far as exactly how powerful Kyle
Rayner is in his white lantern form it's
honestly hard to say his powers seem to
be pretty much limitless and we see him
during a fight in the future during
green lantern new guardians features in
number one where he seems to be
basically omnipotent however it's hard
to really pinpoint what his specific
powers set and power levels are due to
the fact that they haven't really been
fleshed out that well in comics now as
far as weaknesses go it needs to be
mentioned that the white Lantern ring
like all rings has to be periodically
recharged from the power battery that
supplies the ring with power now this
may not necessarily be a weakness so
much as the limitation but is worth
noting anyway but because Kyle's ability
to operate the power ring is dependent
on him being in control of his mind and
emotions it can be inferred that he
would be susceptible to any sort of
psychic or telepathic attack that could
alter his mental or emotional state
furthermore the ability to wheel the
white Lantern ring is contingent on the
wearer's ability to believe in the power
of life without being said if someone
used their psychic or telepathic
abilities to negate Kyle's belief in
this his power level would effectively
diminish and so the question becomes
with all that being said who wins well
honestly this has probably been the
hardest battle that we've done in terms
of declaring a winner these characters
are both powerful reality Wars and when
you're dealing with characters who can
alter the very fabric of reality itself
determining which one is more powerful
is insanely hard both of these
competitors can literally cause any win
that crosses their mind to come to
fruition including wiping each other
from existence and so how do you choose
a winner well I think in order to do
that you have to look at the
shortcomings of each character with that
in mind a lot of this depends on which
version of Franklin Richards were
dealing with if we're dealing with
Franklin as a child which is how he's
most often depicted that I think Kyle
gives
the win here due to his experience and
control over his power the reason why is
that it's been well established that the
child version of Franklin Richards often
does not have full control over his
powers while this can make him more
volatile and dangerous to the point
where his father Reed Richards found it
necessary to create psychic inhibitors
that would suppress his power it also
suggests that in a battle setting
Franklin might not always make the most
rational or strategically sound
decisions and for that reason I think
Kyle will eventually get the win but if
we're talking about adult Franklin
Richards face changed significantly
honestly I don't really know of a way to
distinguish which one of these
characters is stronger based on the
evidence in the comics since both are
depicted as basically being omnipotent
what I think makes a difference here
though is once again the characters
shortcomings specifically Kyle's
vulnerability to telepathy with a
reality warfare like Franklin it's easy
to overlook his other abilities mainly
the fact that he's a powerful telepath
on the cosmic level with that in mind
Franklin should be able to shut down
Kyle's control over his emotions and
thoughts rendering him unable to
effectively wield the white Lantern ring
of course I could see this battle going
either way if I want to be honest with
you guys as both these characters aren't
able to work reality in so many ways
that is impossible to account for them
all but I think this one advantage of
Franklin's telepathy is the one thing
that could tip the scales in his favor
and so ultimately if its adult Franklin
Richards versus the White Lantern Kyle
Rayner
I think the adult Franklin Richards
takes it but I know you guys have
opinions I know somebody's gonna be like
actually robb so post your comments down
below and tell me whether or not you
think I'm right and and what should our
next verses series be I'm kind of
curious what you think our next verses
video should be but if you guys are new
here to comments explain make sure you
hit the subscribe button to become part
of the robb core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you